TO COMMITTEE ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE'S MEETING AT TODAY'S --
JUNE ELEVENTH AND WE HAVE A UP
FOR ITEMS ONE ON CONSENT OF I
THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS WE
CAN CALL ROLE [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
PRESENT [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
I WARNER HARD ROCK.
KALRA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
STONE HERE.
MR STONE IS JOINING US AND IN
PLACE OF MISS OF LONGER RUBIO --
SO WITH THAT WHY DON'T WE TAKE
UP THE CONSENT ITEM AG ARE
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
[inaudible]
OUR MOTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ROLL CALL PLEASE [inaudible]
WELCOME -- YOU DON'T RECALL THAT.
FOR THE CONSENT ITEMS
[inaudible]
CONSENT ITEMS [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
IS YOUR FIFTEEN NAZARIAN.
HI MS ARE IN HIGH VOEPEL.
I WARNER HARD ROCK.
KALRA.
ALL RIGHTS LACKEY.
REYES STONE [inaudible]
STONE AYE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT LET'S START WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT AND I BELIEVE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR HUESO.
ERIN BY NO IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AS STATED AT THE OUTSET I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR WESTERN
PROUD TO PRESENT SB THREE THREE
EIGHT THE BILL WHICH SEEKS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FROM
HARMONY ABUSE. TO THESE VOTER
ONE AT RISK POPULATIONS --
POPULATION GROUPS INCLUDE SENIOR
CALIFORNIANS IN ADULTS AND
CHILDREN LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES AS AN EXAMPLE.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS WITHIN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WE SAW A 37%
INCREASE IN CRIMES AGAINST
SENIORS.
FORTUNATELY IN RESPONSE TO THIS
DRAMATIC INCREASE AND YOU COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER STEVEN.
BROUGHT TOGETHER A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS.
ADD TO TO CREATE A FIRST EVER
THINK TANK TO DEVELOP PLANS AND
ADDRESS ISSUES RELATING TO THIS.
LARGE AND THE SIGNIFICANT UPTAKE
IN ABUSES REPORTED.
ON BEHALF OF SENIOR CALIFORNIANS
THOSE EXPERTS IDENTIFIED GAPS
AND NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
SET GOALS FOR THE FUTURE THIS
INITIATIVE WAS KNOWN AS THE
BLUEPRINT.
AND IS SOUGHT TO ADDRESS --
ELDER ABUSE CASES WHICH
FREQUENTLY GO UNDOCUMENTED.
SB THREE THREE THREE EIGHT WILL
CREATE THE CAIFORNIA SENIOR IN
DISABILITY JUSTICE ACT WHICH
WILL GIVE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TOOLS TO BETTER PROTECT.
SENIOR CITIZENS AND CALIFORNIANS
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES FROM
ABUSE SEXUAL ASSAULT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HATE CRIMES AND MURDER.
FOR THE FIRST TIME ANYWHERE THIS
BILL LISTS ALL CALIFORNIA LAWS
SPECIFICALLY PROTECTING SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
INCLUDING -- BROAD MAJOR LOSSES
SPECIFICALLY FACT THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS LAST YEAR
CENTER CENTER WEST SO AUTHORED
ELEVEN NINETY ONE WHICH WENT
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE.
AND IT HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN
WE'VE HEARD BACK FROM A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE STATE AT
ABOUT HOW EFFECTIVE THAT BILL
HAS TRULY BEEN A BY CODIFYING
SPECIFIC.
PENAL CODES IN A LAW ENFORCEMENT
MANUALS IT HAS A PROVIDE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS WITH A GREAT
RESOURCE. TO TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
BACK TO WHEN THEY COME OF UPON
INSTANCES OF ELDER ABUSE --
TODAY I'M I'M JOINED BY TWO
WITNESSES AND FIRST I WILL BE
TESTIFYING GREG TO GEAR
REPRESENTING THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND SECOND AS SPENCER SACKS ON
BEHALF OF THE MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF
LAW ELDER AND HEALTH LIKE CLINIC
THANK YOU AND JUST. TO REMIND
YOU THIS BILL DOES SUPPORT US --
ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING THE BAY ON
THE GREG HERE REPRESENTING AT
TWO ORGANIZATIONS TO WITH THE
THREE SPONSORS TODAY THE ARC IN
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION.
WHICH IS A COALITION OF PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL TO SELL.
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
FRIENDS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND HAS THIRTY SIX CHAPTERS AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THE OTHER IS THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
WHICH IS THE STATE'S LARGEST A
SENIOR AT THE CITY GROUP WITH A
MILLION MEMBERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I HOPE
I HAVEN'T USED UP MY TIME TO
ISSUES RESOLVED.
I THINK EVERYBODY HERE IS AWARE
OF THE EXPLODING POPULATION OF
YOURS IN CALIFORNIA HOW WE'RE
REALLY NOT READY.
FOR THAT STARTED TO SAY FOR THEM
I SHOULD SAY FOR US -- I'M.
AFTER A MINUTE I'M SO YOU'RE NOT
[inaudible]
THE THE ISSUE OF ABUSE AND OTHER
CRIMES AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING --
DISABILITY CAUSED BY AGING IS
THE ONE THAT I'VE FOLLOWED FOR
ACADEMICALLY AND IN POLICY FOR A
LONG TIME BUT IT REALLY CAME
HOME A FEW YEARS AGO.
WHEN I WAS TALKING TO AN OLDER
WOMAN WITH A DISABILITY WHO --
WAS TELLING ME HOW SHE HAD BEEN
ABUSED -- SHE DIDN'T SAY WHAT
THE ABUSE WAS AYE AYE I THINK IT
WAS SEXUAL ABUSE BUT I COULD BE
WRONG ABOUT THAT BUT HE TO MUTE
BEEN USING SOME SERIOUS WAY.
SHE CALLED THE POLICE I THINK
WAS THE SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND NEVER GOT A RESPONSE -- NO
OFFICER NO CALL NO ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
NOTHING AND THE THE RESEARCH --
SUPPORT AND AND SHE WAS ON THE
VERGE OF TEARS I'VE NEVER
FORGOTTEN THAT -- THE THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT KIND OF
RESPONSE OR NON RESPONSE IS IS
ALL TOO COMMON.
THERE WAS A TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
SURVEY.
OF ADULTS AND CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND 48% OF THE RESPONDENTS WHO
HAD REPORTED THAT THEY HAD BEEN
THE VICTIM OF CRIME SAID NOTHING
HAPPENED WHEN THEY REPORTED TO
POLICE THAT WAS NATIONWIDE MAYBE
WE'RE DOING A LITTLE BIT BETTER
IN CALIFORNIA NOW THANKS.
TO THIS BILL NEXT YEAR LAST YEAR
AND AND OTHER OTHER EFFORTS BUT
IT'S BUT I'VE I'VE CONTINUE TO
HEAR THAT EVEN FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
WHO ARE PART OF THEIR ELDER
INDEPENDENT DON'T USE UNITS TO
pCOLLEAGUES JUST DON'T?
ARE TRAINED ENOUGH AREN'T THAT
THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA PROTOCOLS.
AND THIS BILL WILL DO WILL TAKE
A BIG STEP IN THAT DIRECTION TO
FIX FIX THOSE PROBLEMS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS SPENCER
SACKS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE MAJORITY LEGAL CLINICS.
THE NUMEROUS MCGEORGE LEGAL
CLEMENT A CLINICS WORK CLOSELY
WITH MANY GROUPS WHO ARE OFTEN
IN DIRE NEED OF LEGAL SERVICES.
SPECIFICALLY IN THE ELDER AND
HELP OUR CLINIC AT MCGEORGE THE
STAFF AND LAW STUDENTS WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE COMMUNITY ON
ISSUES ENCOMPASSING ELDER LAW.
LAW STUDENTS UNDERTAKE
REPRESENTATION OF THE ELDERLY
AND THE HOMELESS -- AND THE
HOMELESS IN THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES AREA IN THE AREAS OF
ELDER ABUSE RESTRAINING ORDERS
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
SUCH AS MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
ALL.
ACCESS TO INCOME SERVICES
CONSUMER MATTERS POWERS OF
ATTORNEY -- TRUST ADMINISTRATION
AND ESTATE PLANNING -- FOR OUR
ELDERLY CLIENTS THE CLINIC OFTEN
HANDLES -- THE CIVIL LOOK --
CIVIL LEGAL NEEDS OF THOSE --
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS SUCH
AS A CRIMINAL RECORD EXPUNGEMENT
HANDLE -- REDUCTIONS OF FINES
AND FEES AND CHILD SUPPORT
MODIFICATIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD STRENGTHEN THE
CLINICS ABILITY TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY IN OUR CLINIC BECAUSE
THE POLICE OFFICERS WOULD HAVE
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE TO THEM. TO
CREATE MORE SUBSTANTIAL REPORTS
THAT WE FREQUENTLY OUT RELY ON
IN OUR WORK -- ACCORDING TO THE
GREG SAID HAS THE LARGEST
GROWING -- OF THE LARGEST
GROWING POPULATION IS SENIORS
AND THIS IS OUR FASTEST GROWING
POPULATION IN THE NATION.
THE STATE HAS FALLEN BEHIND IN
ALLOCATING RESOURCES TO PROVE --
PROPERLY PREPARE FOR THIS LARGE
SCALE DEMOGRAPHIC TRANSITION --
LAW ENFORCEMENT MUST BE PREPARED
TO SHED LIGHT ON THESE TYPES OF
CRIMES PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES --
INCLUDING DISABILITIES CAUSED BY
ADVANCED AGE ARE VICTIMIZED BY
VIOLENT CRIMES THREE POINT FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN THOSE
WITHOUT -- FOR THOSE WITH
COGNITIVE DISABILITIES SUCH AS
DEMENTIA INTELLECTUAL
DISPARITIES AND MENTAL ILLNESS
THE RATE IS MORE LIKE FIVE POINT
FIVE TIMES.
THIS VICTIMIZATION IS OFTEN
COMMITTED BY PERPETRATORS THAT
THE VICTIM KNOWS -- INCLUDING
CARETAKERS. TO FURTHER COMPOUND
THIS ISSUE THESE CRIMES ARE
UNDER REPORTED AND THEY ARE
UNDER INVESTIGATED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO MIGHT
NOT BE AWARE OF THE EXTENT OF
THE CRIMES.
OFTEN DISMISSING THEM AS CIVIL
MATTERS -- THIS IS LARGELY
BECAUSE BY SPARSE AND CONSISTENT
TRAINING EDUCATION AND WRITTEN
POLICIES REGARDING THESE TYPES
OF ABUSES.
THROUGH THIS BILL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND OTHER
RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES WILL BETTER
PROTECT SAID AS A SENIOR
CITIZENS AND BETTER PROTECT
ADULTS AND CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES.
THROUGH EFFECTIVE FORMAL
POLICIES BETTER TRAINING AND
OVERALL AWARENESS OF THE
STATUTORY POWERS
RESPONSIBILITIES PARTICULAR TO
THESE CRIMES.
SB THREE THREE EIGHT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES THE
EDUCATION AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WILL UPDATE
A LOT OF REQUIRE THEIR POLICIES
AND TRAINING TO BETTER ADDRESS
THE SAFETY OF SENIORS AND
DISABLED CITIZENS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME --
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CHAPTER TO KIA.
A HOME CARE A WHOLE.
HAVING SOME PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND TO RECOMMEND IS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHEN THIS
FIRST WAS BROUGHT UP AS AN
EDUCATION EFFORT PUT SUPPORT
THIS.
THANK YOU.
CINDY SEPARATE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAROL SO FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DANIEL SAVANNAH ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT NEXT CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS THIS WORK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHURKIN A
MINUTE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M JOE
RODRIGUEZ THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
I MEAN INDEPENDENT ADVOCATE FOR
RESIDENTS OF LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES HOUSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
BUT MY OPINIONS DO NOT
NECESSARILY REPRESENT THE
OPINIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
ARE YOU MISTER CHAIR CRISTINA
BUS HAMILTON REPRESENTING YOU W. --
I JUST US HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND I
JUST AS WORKERS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN TO MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WHERE HER IN SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS ARE AT GREATEST RISK
OF ABUSE.
THANK YOU.
JUDY JACKSON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NO.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BRIEFLY
BRIEFLY THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS
AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IN
THE SENATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THIS IS YOUR FIRST PRESENTATION
ON BEHALF OF YOUR BOSS IT IS HE
DID A GOOD JOB THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
FIRST BURST IN THE SAME.
AS A FIRST AND A SECOND LET'S
CALL THE ROLL.
SB THREE THREE EIGHT NAZARIAN.
HI NAZARIAN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I BORDER HARD ROCK.
KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY.
REYES.
REYES AYE STONE.
STONE I MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FOUR NINETY
SIX BY SENATOR MORLOCK
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
PONDERED BE HERE.
WATCH A REAL PRO IN ACTION HERE
THRILLED ALIVE.
FLATTERY DOESN'T GET YOU
ANYWHERE SENATOR.
GET THAT STAFFER BACK INTERNET.
ALL HAVE BEEN TO MY BILL.
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
IT WILL MAKE A BRIEF.
PRESENTATION PLEASE IF YOU WANT
TO I CAN I'LL I'LL I'LL TRY.
TO NARROW DOWN JUST TO GET THE
THE GIST OF IT BUT WHEN YOU LOOK
UP ELDER FINANCIAL ABUSE ON
GOOGLE AND THE DEFINITION COMES
UP.
A TYPE OF ABUSE AND WHICH
MISAPPROPRIATION OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES.
OR ABUSIVE USE OF FINANCIAL
CONTROL IN THE CONTEXT OF A
RELATIONSHIP WHERE THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION OF TRUST.
CAUSES HARM. TO AN OLDER PERSON.
AND SO YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
ENOUGH HORROR STORIES OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING OUT THERE INCLUDING
TELEPHONE SCAMS ETCETERA.
SENATE BILL FOUR NINE SIX WHICH
IS KNOWN AS THE PROTECTIONS
AGAINST FINANCIAL ABUSE OF ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS.
GIVES FINANCIAL INDUSTRY
PARTICIPANTS THE STATE
REGULATORS NEW TOOLS TO HELP
DETECT AND PREVENT THE FINANCIAL
ABUSE OF VULNERABLE ADULTS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE MANDATES FOR
BANKS -- TO REPORT ANY ABUSE.
A WHAT WE'RE DOING IS ADDING
STOCKBROKERS AND FINANCIAL
ADVISERS.
AND WE'RE USING.
A STANDARD FORMAT THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN ADOPTED BY NINETEEN STATES
AND APPROVED BY THE INDUSTRY AND
I HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GREAT.
THE PRESENTATION THANK YOU
JOANNE BUT IN COURT REPRESENTING
THE SECURITIES INDUSTRY AND
FINANCIAL MARKETS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
AB.
BREAK LIABILITY WITH THAT
FINANCIAL SERVICES INSTITUTE AND
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
ANY ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
JEFF STARTED YEAR AND ASI SPOKE
I SACRAMENTO SENIOR CASE CAME UP
WITH FINANCIAL ABUSE SOME YEARS
AGO.
OPEN BIG TIME I KNEW THE
INDIVIDUAL SHE RECENTLY DIED.
BUT INDEED THAT OCCURRED TO HER
KASTRO HOME.
THANK YOU SORRY.
MANY X. CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHT STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THE WITNESSES NO COMMENTS GREAT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
OR COMMENTS YES MISS RACE.
ALL.
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT TALKS IT'S
A GOOD BILL AND SUPPORTING IT.
I I ALWAYS AM CONCERNED WHEN
SOMEONE IS GIVEN MORE POLICE
POWERS -- AND THERE IS A COMMENT
IN THE ANALYSIS THE TALKS SAYS
THAT.
LIKELY TO HAVE THE GREATEST
POTENTIAL. TO CROSS THE LINE
BETWEEN ABUSE PREVENTION AND
INTRUSIVE OVER PROTECTION.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE OVERLY OVERLY ZEALOUS --
FINANCIAL ADVISORS WHO THEN STOP.
A TRANSACTION FROM HAPPENING --
AND I ESPECIALLY CONCERNED IF.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS ONE DAY
TO ANOTHER MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE IF YOU'RE SELLING
STOCKS -- ANOTHER IS IF THERE IS
IF -- IF THEY DIE IN THE
MEANTIME WHILE SOMEBODY IS
INVESTIGATING THIS WHAT
PROTECTIONS ARE THERE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
THOSE.
THE INTRUSIVE OVER PROTECTIONS
NOTED IN THE INTEL'S.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND AND
AGAIN.
IN LIFE -- WHEN WHEN YOU'RE IN A
PROFESSION AND YOU SEND
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT NOT BE
RIGHT?
SOMETIMES A RE.
GONNA BE -- PROTECTED IF YOU
FOLLOW YOUR HUNCH OR YOUR
INTUITION SO NOW THE ISSUE IS IF
YOU'RE WRONG WHAT -- WHAT KIND
OF REMEDIES ARE THERE -- IF IF
YOU WERE TO SAY -- NOT BELIEVE
THAT OUR POWER OF ATTORNEY IS
ACCURATE THAT IT MIGHT BE
FABRICATED -- BECAUSE FRAUD IS.
SOMETHING EASILY TO PERPETRATE A
E. YOU WOULD YOU WOULD PROBABLY
AS A BUSINESS PROFESSIONAL
CONTACT A LAWYER THAT DRAFTED
YOU PROBABLY ALREADY IN IN THE
STATE PLANNING -- CIRCLE OF
INFLUENCE FOR YOU KNOW MOST THE
PLAYERS IN YOUR CITY IN TOWN.
AND YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO REMEDY
AND AND CONFIRM YOUR SUSPICIONS.
WITHIN AN HOUR BY MAKING A FEW
PHONE CALLS AND IF IF IF THAT
DOESN'T SOLVE IT FOR YOU AND YOU
YOU UPSET A TRADE OR OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
DIDN'T NOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE BETTER BUSINESS
BUREAU AND AND EVEN YOUR FOR
YOUR YOUR PROFESSIONAL
REPUTATION IN THE INDUSTRY.
SO YOU'RE GONNA BE EXTREMELY
CAUTIOUS WHEN YOU WHEN YOU MAKE
A MOVE LIKE THIS -- I CAN ONLY
GIVE ONE STORY WITH WITH MY OWN
FATHER -- WE DECIDED IT WOULD BE
GOOD FOR MY SISTER TO BE THE
CONSERVATIVE.
AND SO SHE STARTED GOING TO THE
BANK RECORDS AND THERE WAS A
CHARGE CHARGES ON MY DAD'S MY
FOR MY FOLKS BANK STATEMENT
EVERY MONTH.
CONTACT THE BANK AND SAYS WHAT
ARE THESE THOUGHTS FRIED BUT
WHAT WE DO WELL WE CLOSE THE
ACCOUNT WELL THEN.
MY POWER OF ATTORNEY AND THE TO
OPEN A NEW ACCOUNT THEY SAID NO.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT ON
THE TRUST.
AND AND ALL REVIEW DAYS LATER
SHE FOUND A POLICE OFFICER AT
OUR FRONT DOOR.
CONFIRMING THAT SHE WAS THE
RIGHT PERSON.
BUT SHE WAS.
AUTHORIZED CONSIDER CENTER IN IN
IN HALF OF US WENT LIKE BOY
THAT'S REALLY LIKE OVER KILL THE
OTHER HALF OF A SAID ISN'T NICE.
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY PROTECTING
THE ASSETS OF OUR FOLKS.
SO WE HAVE THOSE REMEDIES AND
AND AND MY WITNESSES MAY HAVE
SOME ANECDOTAL STORIES AS WELL.
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
PLEASE.
ALSO THE BILL SETS UP THE FACT
THAT YOU MUST HAVE AT LEAST TWO
MANDATED REPORTERS LOOKING AT
THE TRANSACTION.
SO IT'S NOT JUST ONE ADVISER YOU
KNOW MAKING ALL THE DECISIONS
[inaudible]
I MAY I HAVE YOUR THE CHECK
ADDITIONALLY IT THEY CAN ONLY
WITH HOLD THE FUNDS WERE FOR
THIRTY DAYS.
SO THEY CAN'T MAXIM THIRTY DAYS
SO.
BUT AT THE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MISTRESS.
THANK YOU SCORE -- A NICE.
ONE THANK THOSE THAT ARE SUPPORT
AS WELL SENATOR -- AND THEY HAVE
INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT --
OFTENTIMES WITH THESE MEASURES
ARE.
THE PRECEDING WOMEN WHEN ONE FOR
SEIZE ON THESE MEASURES
OFTENTIMES INDUSTRY OPPOSES
BECAUSE IT IS TAX OBLIGATION.
CEMEX RESPONSIBILITY AND EVEN
OPEN YOURSELF UP TO SMALL HELL
BENT ON HIS AS OF THE FACT THAT
YOUR SUPPORT IS VERY MEANINGFUL.
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO BUT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE TAKE ABOUT TO
GET AROUND TO GETTING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND SAW IT'S A
PORTION OF THE FCT THAT.
EVERYONE'S ON BOARD IT'S FOR THE
RIGHT REASON AND WITH THE
CAUTIONS FROM A SUMMER REYES I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THIS COULD BE A
VERY POSITIVE -- DEVELOPMENT OUR
STATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE THE SERVER Và.
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES -- I
ALSO POINT OUT TO EVERYONE THAT --
I PERSONALLY HOLD VERY AS
FINANCIAL SERVICES OUR LICENSES
AND HAVE FOR THIRTY NINE YEARS --
THEIR NUMBER -- ONE CALL TO
ORDER IS.
KNOW YOUR CLIENT.
SO THEY KNOW THEIR CLIENTS
THEY'RE REQUIRED.
TO SAY WEBER BANKS SO THIS BILL
SIMPLY REINFORCES THE PERSON
THAT KNOWS THE CLIENT THE MOST
AND WHEN THEY SEE AN ANOMALY OR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
ESPECIALLY A NEW PERSON THAT
COMES INTO THE CLIENT'S LIFE.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAVE WEIRD
EYES.
BEEN THERE DONE THAT.
SO THIS IS A GREAT BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT [inaudible]
ANYBODY ELSE.
OKAY -- CLOSING STATEMENTS I I
THINK -- THE SERMON KALRA HIT
RIGHT ON ON THAT ON THE HEAD WE
HAVE INDUSTRY SUPPORTING THIS
BILL WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THEM
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS AND THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE DOING WITH
OUR GROWING ELDERLY POPULATION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
FLATTERY DIDN'T WIN ME OVER BUT
THE BILL DID SO I I'D BE HONORED
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AS
WELL I'LL TAKE A VOTE FROM
HANSON CHERRY.
YOU LAY IT ON DAY.
ONE RITE AID -- DO WE HAVE A THE
SECOND ENOUGH -- FIRST AND A
SECOND.
WE DO OKAY PERFECT -- IT'S CALL
THE ROLL.
SB FOUR NINETY SIX NAZARIAN.
HI DESIGN I'D VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE.
WARNER HARD ROCK.
WARNER BROTH I KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES I STONE.
STONE AYE THE MEASURE PASSES.
AND JUST SO I KNOW IT WAS A
SEVEN MEMBER STONE.
WITH THE FIRST THEN SOMEONE
MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU A MISTER VOEPEL OKAY
THANK YOU.
I HEARD YOUR FIRST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PERFECT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE GREAT
JOB -- WHILE THE SURGEON IS A
PREPARING THE TABLE BUT WHY
DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND GO THROUGH
THE BILLS AND JUST ADD ON THE
VOTES -- SO ITEM NUMBER ONE AG
ARE.
FIFTEEN CONSENT ITEM WITH THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOMS BILL --
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CHAIR FIFTEEN BORDER HER
ROCK.
WARNER HOME HARD ROCK I REYES
[inaudible]
REYES AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT BY.
SENATOR BEN HUESO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SB.
THREE THREE EIGHT WARNER HARD
ROCK [inaudible]
ROTH I REYES.
RESIGN THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE JUST ABOUT
READY WELCOME SENATOR PAT.
RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
AFTERNOON. TO BEGIN.
PLEASE START ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
A WINNER ROGER TO BE HERE AND
PRESENT TO SUCH A DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE.
I THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO
SB.
FIVE TWELVE WHICH TAKES FIRST
CRITICAL STEP IN CREATING A NEW
LONG TERM SERVICES -- SUPPORT
AND SUPPORTS OUR L. TSS BENEFIT
FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION IS
THE BENEFIT IS URGENT ALMOST
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE
EITHER OLDER ADULTS ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE WITH
PHYSICAL MENTAL DISABILITIES
CURRENTLY LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS POPULATION WILL CONTINUE
TO GROW SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
NEXT DECADE.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CALIFORNIANS
LACK ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE L. D.
S. A SERVICES.
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
ARE NOT ADEQUATELY COVERED BY
MEDICARE AND MOST CALIFORNIANS
CANNOT AFFORD TO PURCHASE
PRIVATE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
PAYING OUT OF POCKET FOR L. TSS
IS HIGHLY EXPENSIVE AND CREATES
A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL AND
SOCIAL BIRD FOR FAMILIES.
ALTERNATIVELY CALIFORNIANS THEN
MUST SPEND DOWN THROUGH THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS TO BECOME ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDICARE NOW. TOO OFTEN THIS
MEANS THEY PRIMARY.
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
CURRENTLY RECEIVE ACCESS TO PAY
LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
AND CERTAINLY WELL MEDI CAL IS A
CRITICAL SAFETY NET SYSTEM THE
SAFETY THAT SYSTEM IS
OVERBURDENED.
AND THAT ALSO OF COURSE MEANS
THAT MORE TAX DOLLARS THAT WE
HAVE TO ALLOCATE.
INDIVIDUAL SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
IMPOVERISH THEMSELVES.
SPEND THROUGH THE LIFE SAVINGS
IN THEIR CHILDREN'S INHERITANCE
OR TO FOREGO WORKING AND
GENERATING.
EARNED INCOME IN ORDER TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THEY NEED
TO LIVE INDEPENDENT HIGH QUALITY
LIVES.
THIS LEGISLATION CREATES A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE MANAGEMENT OF
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
BENEFITS TO BE AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE TWELVE
CREATES THE INFRASTRUCTURE
MODELED AFTER TO CAL SEAVER
SECURE CHOICE PROGRAM FOR ONE
CALIFORNIA'S RATE TO DESIGN AND
FINANCE THE NEW BENEFIT.
INDEED THIS LEGISLATION IS
SPONSOREDBY CALIFORNIA AGING
AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE WHICH
REPRESENTS TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM OF L. D. S.
TO STAKEHOLDERS.
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD NOW TO
PUT THESE CRITICAL PIECES IN
PLACE SO WE CAN CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD WITH BENEFIT AND
FINANCING DESIGN.
AND PLEASE TO THE HAVE THAT WILL
HAVE THE HEARING TESTIMONY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENCE CENTERS AND A. R.
P. AS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS
ALLEY CANNINGTON AND I'M THE
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
SEE A FILE SEAT.
WE ARE MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION
FOR CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT LET
LIVING NETWORK AND CURRENTLY
REPRESENT TWENTY TWO OUT OF THE
TWENTY EIGHT CENTERS INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS ARE ADVOCACY AND
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS.
RUN FOR AND BY PEOPLE WITH ALL
KINDS OF DISABILITIES THEY ARE
NOT PLACES YOU LIVE INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS PROVIDE A WIDE
RANGE OF SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH ALL TYPES OF DISABILITIES
ACROSS THEIR LIFESPAN.
TODAY I'M REALLY HONORED TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S DISABLED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND ADVOCATES YOU ALONG
THE VARGAS.
WHO WILL BE IT WHO HAS BEEN
WILLING TO SHARE HER PERSONAL
STORY AND THE POSITIVE IMPACT
THAT SB FIVE TWELVE COULD HAVE
ON HER LIFE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS IN ONE OF OUR
GUESTS I'VE LIVED IN SACRAMENTO
FOR SEVEN YEARS I'VE USED THE
WILSHIRE.
SINCE BIRTH.
I WOULD.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT SB.
FIVE TWELVE WHEN I SAY THAT I
HAVE LIVED IN SACRAMENTO FOR
SEVEN YEARS I'VE REALLY LIVED
I'VE TRAVELED ALL OVER THE U. S.
BEING AN ADVOCATE AND ACTIVIST
FOR THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
I WILL ALWAYS NEED A WHEELCHAIR.
MY CONDITION WILL NEVER CHANGE
IT IS NOT A SOB FACT BUT A
NEUTRAL ONE THE SKY IS BLUE
WATER IS WHAT.
AND A LOT OF ARGUES ME THE
WHEELCHAIR. ONE MY WILSHIRE
BROKE THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
THAT EVENT RIPPLED THROUGHOUT MY
LIFE.
I WAS PART OF A SPECIAL PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWED DISABLED PEOPLE WHO
WORKED TO KEEP THEIR MEDI CAL AT
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID COVERAGE
SO EVEN AFTER I LOST MY JOB I
SHOULD HAVE BEEN FINE.
BUT BECAUSE THE PAPERWORK MAKE
MIX UPS ENDED UP LOSING MY
MEDICAID AND SPEND MONTHS TRYING
TO GET MY SERVICES.
GOING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
SYSTEMS WITH NO ONE ABLE TO GIVE
ME A CLEAR ANSWER WHEN MY
BENEFITS WILL BE REINSTATED.
FINANCIALLY IT WAS BARELY
HOLDING ON MY ROOMMATE HAD
STOPPED PAYING RENT IN ADDITION
I WAS IN CONSTANT AGONY BECAUSE
OF A DENTAL EMERGENCY THAT I
COULDN'T AFFORD TO FIX.
JUST LIKE I COULDN'T AFFORD TO
FIX MY WILSHIRE.
ABOUT SITUATION WAS MADE TEN
TIMES WORSE BECAUSE I DIDN'T
HAVE DEPENDABLE -- TSS AS A
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL WITH
DISABILITIES.
I AM A SELF SUFFICIENT DISABLED
WOMAN WHO'S BEEN ABLE TO
COORDINATE MY SERVICE THESE FOR
AS LONG AS I CAN REMEMBER.
BUT HAVING A FEW MISSING SCREWS.
BUT I COULD NOT AFFORD OUT OF
POCKET DESTROYED THE
INDEPENDENTS BUT I WORK SO HARD
TO BUILD.
AND PUT ME IN A WHOLE NEW
CATEGORY OF VULNERABILITY.
THROUGHOUT THIS PAST YEAR I HAVE
BEEN.
BETWEEN DISAPPOINTED HEALTH
INSURANCE EN EL TSS I NEED MORE
OPTIONS AND THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF OTHER QUALIFIED YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES JUST LIKE ME.
WHO NEED MORE OPTIONS SB FIVE
TWELVE NEEDS TO BE ONE OF THESE
OPTIONS?
MY MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY NEED.
NEEDED ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS.
A BECOME WEAKER BECAUSE THAT I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO HAVE THE
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY OF PUSHING MY
WILSHIRE DURING MY RECENT LTFS.
CRISIS I NOW.
HAVE TO DEAL WITH PRESSURE SORES
ON TOP OF MY DAILY NEEDS BECAUSE
THEY BEING STUCK WITH THE CHAIR
THAT NEEDED A NEW SEAT CUSHION.
ALL OF WHICH TRANSLATE STATIC
COST TO AN ALREADY OVERWHELMED
MEDICAL SYSTEM.
I WANT TO BE AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
MY COMMUNITY I WANT TO GO BACK
TO WORK I CAN ONLY CALL PUSH MY
GOALS IF I HAVE SUFFICIENT
ALTIUS.
AS TO GET ME THERE.
I SUPPORT SB FIVE TWELVE AND ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT US BE FIVE TWELVE
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES A FREE WORK
NEEDED FOR ME AND THOUSAND THE
THOUSANDS OF AGING AND DISABLED.
OF HIS OLD INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE STATE WHO WANT TO BE
CONTRIBUTING TAXPAYERS AND I
WANT TO LIVE A QUALITY OF LIFE
WITH DEPENDABLE.
LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
GERMAN WEDDING.
MY NAME IS DAVID FEINBERG I AM A
VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO REPRESENT A A RP
IN ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
A A RP IS A MEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA AGING ALLIANCE AND
WITH A VERY ACTIVE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT THIS BILL ALONG WITH
THE WITH THE SENATOR.
THE COST OF LONG TERM CARE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT BECAUSE AT SOME
POINT WE WILL ALL AGE INTO THAT
KIND OF SITUATION.
ALL.
NORMAL FAMILIES THAT ARE TRYING
TO TAKE CARE OF THE ELDERLY OR
SICK INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED THAT
KIND OF CARE OFTEN HAVE TO GIVE
UP THEIR JOB BUT EVEN IF THEY
DON'T.
JUST THE MERE COSTA MAINTAINING
AND A FIFTEEN CAN BE MORE THAN A
FAMILY BUDGET CAN TAKE.
AVERAGE PERSON WHO IS SUPPORTING
A FAMILY AS A FAMILY CARETAKER
SPENDING ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH OUT OF THEIR OWN.
POCKET IF YOU HAVE THE CARD WITH
ALZHEIMER'S OR THE KINDER TO
MATCH IT COULD BE AS MUCH AS
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WHERE
DOES THE AVERAGE FAMILY GET THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN THE PERSON.
IN WORST CASE SCENARIOS
INDIVIDUAL HAS TO GO ON AN
INSTITUTION IN WHICH CASE
INSTITUTIONAL COSTS BECOME MUCH
GREATER THAN MOST FAMILIES CAN
SUPPORT AND IF YOU DO YOU WIND
UP TAKING.
FROM THE NEXT GENERATION WHO
WON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES MY SITUATION
IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT I HAVE
A NINETY FOUR YEAR OLD MOTHER.
WHO LIVES IN THE MIDDLE?
A MEMORY KERR UNIT ON A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FACILITY FACILITY
COSTS A LITTLE OVER NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH SHE
GETS TWO THOUSAND AND THE SOCIAL
SECURITY AND VETERANS PENSION.
AND THREE THOUSAND FROM HOSPICE
CARE THAT.
FIVE THOUSAND WHERE DOES THE
OTHER FOUR THOUSAND COME FROM
SHE HAS NO SAVINGS TO PAY FOR
THAT SO AS AN ONLY CHILD I PAY
FOR IT.
YES I'M TAKING THAT MONEY OUT OF
MY OWN RETIREMENT POCKET SO WHEN
MY WIFE AND I IN THE NEXT
FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS REACHED
THE POINT WHERE WE NEED THAT
KIND OF CARE.
WHERE'S THE RESOURCE GOING TO BE
TO DO THAT FOR THOSE KINDS OF
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I AM ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
USE AYE HSS UNDER MEDI CAL.
I SOCIAL WORKER RECENTLY TOLD ME
THE REASON SHE HAS TROUBLE
GETTING BACK TO ME.
IS THAT SHE HAS FOUR HUNDRED
CLIENTS RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S NOT A SYSTEM THAT THE
STATE SHOULD BE UNDER.
THANK YOU.
GIVEN THE LINE WE HAVE WHY DON'T
WE JUST KEEP IT TO THE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
CINDY SMITH WITH A STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CAROL SUE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF TWO ORGANIZATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKER
COALITION AND HAND IN HAND
EMPLOYERS NETWORK THANK YOU SO
MUCH IN SUPPORT.
BLAKE JOHNSON HER BATH STATE
SHOULD A FEW ON A MARK HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PETER TELL US ON BEHALF OF
LEADING AIDS CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING NOT FOR PROFIT --
PORTABLE SENIOR HOUSING ASSISTED
LIVING IN SKILLED NURSING
PROVIDERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IF ANYONE WITH THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPORT AND ALSO A
PROUD MEMBER OF CADE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA MEMBER ACADIA
AND IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
RAIN X. CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
THANKS THANKS AGAIN.
THE CONTRAST OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THIS ISN'T A MORRIS ON BEHALF OF
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT AND WE'RE ALSO A PROUD
MEMBER OF KAYLA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PETER HAS SOLD COPIES --
REPRESENTING THE PROGRAMS OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
AND SUPPORT THE BILL AND ALO A
MEMBER OF CARE.
THANK YOU.
CRISTINA BUS HAMILTON YOU W.
REPRESENTING HSS WORKERS ALSO
MEMBER OF QUEDA -- VERY PROUD OF
OUR HISTORIC ALLIANCE IN URGING
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STEVEN WEBER WITH ASKED ME
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN HEYMAN WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES AND A MEMBER OF KATE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ROCK SINGLE WAS SIX BEDS DOT ORG
IS A AN ASSOCIATION SMALL
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND DEVELOPMENT
DISABLED IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU. THREE SANDERSON WITH
OUR CAN UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT AND ALSO PROUD MEMBER OF
QUEDA.
THANK YOU.
AMY BLOOMBERG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO JEFF TOWARD A GEAR
PERSONALLY IN SUPPORT OF IT.
ADVOCATING FOR KERA.
ADVOCATING FOR OUR ADVOCATING
FOR DOG BITE ADVOCATING FOR A
COUPLE OTHERS AND I'LL GET THE
WORD BACK.
THANK YOU -- ANYONE THERE I SAY
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS YES
MISTER KALRA.
AS CHAIR OF THANK YOU SENATOR --
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL.
FORWARD I'M PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT.
EVERYONE PRETTY MUCH THAT SPOKE
IN AND AND MANY THAT AREN'T IN
THE ROOM.
HAVE BEEN -- WILL FOCUS ON THIS
OF WORKING ON THIS LONG BEFORE I
EVER JOINED LEGISLATURE IS SO
I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT JOINING WITH
THE SENATOR.
IN AND PUSHING THIS FORWARD I
LEARNED VERY QUICKLY -- WHEN I
FIRST JOINED THE ASSEMBLY WE HAD
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON ON LONG
TERM CARE SERVICES LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE AND THE --
ESSENTIAL NONEXISTENCE OF OF IT
AND AND AND THE VIABILITY OF IT
THAT I MEAN WE KNOW.
THAT -- THEY WERE IN A CRISIS
AND IT'S A CRISIS WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED THE CARE
TO CRISIS FOR THE FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT CARE FOR THEM.
AND IT'S CRISIS BY HSS WORKERS
AND OTHERS THAT ARE THE
CARETAKERS THAT CAN BARELY CARE
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND SO -- WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
CARE TAKERS -- AS WELL.
AS THOSE THAT ARE RECEIVING THE
CARE -- OUR BRUCE LITERALLY
SAVING THE STATE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR BY PUTTING UP
THEIR OWN MONEY OR BY
SACRIFICING.
OR BY GOING WITHOUT.
A AND SO.
THE SYSTEMS UNSUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE WE CAN'T EXPECT.
THOSE THAT RECEIVE THE CARE AND
PROVIDE THE CARE TO CONTINUE TO
GO ON THIS WAY.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
SO THAT WE CAN TRULY CREATE A
PATH FORWARD THAT COULD THAT
SUSTAINABLE THAT RESPECTS THOSE
THAT ARE RECEIVING THE CARE AS
WELL AS THOSE PROVIDING THE CARE.
AND THAT ULTIMATELY -- MIGHT
REALLY SAVES THE STATE --
BECAUSE THE STATE THAT A IS NOT
ONLY -- SUSTAINING IN ABLE TO
SUSTAIN -- THE CURRENT A MODEL
OF ON THE BACKS OF SO MANY BUT
ALSO IN THE STATE'S GOING TO
COLLAPSE UNDER UNDER THE WEIGHT
OF THE OF THE BURDENS OF THE
NEEDS.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE WITH THE
GROWING CERTAINLY THE GROWING
ELDERLY POPULATION AND THOSE
THAT HAVE THE NEEDS.
BUT EVEN IF WE WERE JUST TO STAY
STATUS QUO IN TERMS OF NUMBERS
IT'S JUST UNSUSTAINABLE SYSTEM.
AND SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO TRULY MOVE FORWARD --
BUT I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CHALLENGE THAT
DOES PROVIDES PROVIDE SOME HOPE
AND SOME -- SOME EXCITEMENT --
WITH THAT WITH OUR
ADMINISTRATION AND I I KNOW THAT --
IS LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES -- IN
IN IN A FRESH WAY WITH OUR OUR
CHAIR WHO I KNOW CARES DEEPLY
ABOUT THESE ISSUES I THINK WE
CAN ACTUALLY REALLY MOVE THE
BALL FORWARD ABOVE UNDER THE
SENATORS LEADERSHIP SO -- WITH
THAT I WAS A RESPECTFULLY MOVE
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU MISTER
VOEPEL [inaudible]
SOME.
I LOOK UPON THIS BILL SENATOR AS
SIMPLY BEGINNING RIGHT.
I'VE BEEN IN FINANCIAL SERVICES
AS I STATED EARLIER FOR MANY
YEARS I'VE OBSERVE LONG TERM
CARE.
SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND EVERY
TWO YEARS I TAKE A LONG TERM
CARE REFRESHER COURSE SO I'M UP
TO SPEED.
I'M CONSIDERED AN INDUSTRY
EXPERT AT LEAST BY MAY.
I'M ALSO THE VICE CHAIR OF
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT.
NOW IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR JUST
TAKE A FEW SECONDS HERE. ONE THE
PROBLEMS WITH LONG TERM CARE IS
A CANNOT BE ACTUAL WARILY
SUPPORTED OR FINANCED.
THE SILVER SOON A MOMMY IS JUST.
TOO STEEP IT'S A MASSIVE GROUP
OF MAY COME IN AT GOING TO BE
SIXTY NINE YEARS OLD.
WHEN IT'S MY TIME I WANT MY
MONEY OKAYI WANT YOU TO TAKE
CARE OF ME?
I DON'T WANT TO BE IN A
WHEELCHAIR PARKED IN A OF
PASSAGE WAY.
HUB THE HUB.
DOPED UP.
CAN YOU CHANGE MY DEPENDS TWICE
A DAY THAT'S NOT THE WAY I WANT
TO LIVE.
ALRIGHT SO THIS BILL IS SIMPLY A
SIMPLE STEP.
IN THAT DIRECTION TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE TAKING CARE OF NOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT.
AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS IN
TROUBLE IN THIS ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
ONCE AGAIN I'M ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT VICE CHAIR.
THAT SPURS AND STIRRERS RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A MAJOR LAWSUIT
AGAINST PERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE BILLION DOLLAR
PLUS.
BECAUSE HERS IS BEING ACCUSED OF
UNDER FUNDING.
THEIR LONG TERM CARE PLAN FOR
OUR OWN EMPLOYEES.
WELL.
IN MY ACTUARIAL VIEW POINT.
A HIGHLY TRAINED NERD.
IT'S INEVITABLE MOST OF THE
INSURANCE CARRIERS A PULLED OUT.
OF THIS MARKE PLACE NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT UNITED
STATES TRAVELERS CIGNA MANY OF
THESE COMPANIES HAVE GOTTEN OUT
OF THE BUSINESS.
SO BY DEFAULT IT WILL BE
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BILL IS KEY SO I
SUPPORTED A 100% -- BUT I'D
REMIND EVERYONE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TRYING TO DO GOOD
THROUGH PURRS.
IS BEING SUED NOW BY THE VERY
EMPLOYEES WE TRIED TO HELP OUT.
SO KEEP THAT IN MIND.
IS THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT AREA.
AND THERE'S PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH
MONEY.
IN ON THE PLANET TO TAKE CARE OF
EVERYONE AND IN THIS STATE.
SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COURAGE I
APPRECIATE YOUR INGENUITY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OUT WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
CHAIRED JERRY AND I I'VE FOR SO
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK.
SOME MEMBER KALRA FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND PROUD TO HAVE --
THE SEVEN MEMBERS MY PRINCIPAL
CO AUTHOR AND ONCE RECOGNIZE HIS
LEADERSHIP AND THE PORTS OF HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS BILL AND
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS -- FOR OUR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE PEOPLE
DISABILITIES -- IN TERMS OF
PROFICIENCY THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES I'M I THINK IT'S SUMMER
VOEPEL FOR YOUR COMMENTS YOU
KNOW THIS IS THE FIRST STEP WE
WANT TO LOOK AT THIS IT'S A IT'S
A CHALLENGING.
ONE BUT WE NEED TO CREATE MORE
OPTIONS FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS
RIGHT -- WHAT WE HAVE IS WE HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE TO
BASICALLY SPEND DOWN THE POVERTY
AND THEN YOU BECOME SOMEONE THAT
THE STATE AND ALL OF US WE'RE
GOING TO THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
NOW HAS TO THEN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO FIND?
WE ARE TRAPPING PEOPLE
DISABILITIES INTO POVERTY
BECAUSE OF THE ACTUALLY
CONTRIBUTE AND MAKE MONEY THEN
THEY NO LONGER QUALIFY THEN THEY
LOSE THEIR SERVICES AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO BACK OUT AGAIN.
RIGHT AND AND FOR OUR SENIORS WE
HAVE MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES TO
BASICALLY OR WIPING OUT THERE
FOR YOU KNOW PARENTS SAVINGS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE TO IN ORDER TO
YES MANY OF THEM ARE.
TRYING TO PITCH IN AS MUCH THEY
CAN'T OUT THEIR OWN POCKET.
AND HELD THAT DOESN'T WORK AND
THEN AGAIN WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO FIND FUNDED AT THE STATE
WE NEED TO CREATE MORE OPTIONS --
FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS ACTUAR EARLY WE GOT
THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE GET TELL
WE PULL THOSE RESOURCES TO TAKE
TO TRY TO DRESS THE SILVER
TSUNAMI TO BE SURE THAT.
ALL OF US AS WE GET OLDER AND
HOPEFULLY WE DO GET THERE I MEAN
THAT ALTERNATIVE IS NOT REALLY
WHAT I WANT TO CONTEMPLATE. TO
GET OLDER AND BE ABLE TO LIVE IN
DIGNITY -- AS WELL AND ALSO BE
SURE THAT ALL OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS OF DISABILITIES -- CAN
LIVE IN DIGNITY AS WELL SO I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THIS BILL DOES ENJOY SUPPORT
SUPPORT IT'S BEEN -- A MOVED BY
AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
SECONDED BY SOMEONE NUMBER STONE
UP I SUPPORT IT VERY MUCH THANK
YOU I THINK ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE WERE EXTREMELY
APPROPRIATE SO I DON'T NEED TO
ADD ANYTHING.
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT I ALSO A
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO JOIN
US A CO AUTHOR AS WELL SO THANK
YOU.
AND WITH THAT LET'S CALL THE
ROLL.
SB FIVE TWELVE NAZARIAN AYE
NAZARIAN AYE VOEPEL.
I WARNER HORROCKS.
WARNER HER ROTH AYE KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY.
LACKEY I'D REYES.
HIS EYES STONE BY STONE EYES THE
MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE WE VERY QUICKLY GO
THROUGH -- THANK [inaudible]
YOU.
THE BILL THEN ADDS ON AND IF I
CAN ASK THE MEMBERS TO STAY FOR
A MINUTE [inaudible]
LET ME.
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIJI ARE FIFTEEN
BY SOMEONE MEMBER BLOOM --
CONSENT ITEM.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT.
MEMBERS AG ARE FIFTEEN NIKE AYE
LACKEY AYE -- ITEM NUMBER.
TWO SB.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT LACKEY HI LACKEY
AYE.
AND ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FOUR
NINETY SIX BY MORE LOCK.
SB FOUR NINETY SIX LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE.
I SHOULD HAVE -- I SHOULD HAVE
MADE THIS PRESENTATION OR SAID
THESE WORDS BEFORE -- ASKING FOR
THE ADD ONS BUT THIS WILL BE THE
LAST MEETING THAT -- ARE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT BERRY
BREWER -- WILL BE STAFFING --
AND IT'S SOMEWHAT WITH THE WITH
THE WITH.
YEAH I I'M ONLY GETTING THE
OPPORTUNITY NOW IT'S ONLY BEEN A
FEW MONTHS. TO BE ABLE TO WORK
MISS WITH MISTER BREWER AND GET
TO KNOW HIM AND HE'S TOILED IN
THE STATE HE SAID COMMITTED
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF SERVICE TO
THE STATE.
HAVING WORKED WITH MEMBERS LIKE --
FORMER MEMBERS -- CHESBRO RUSKIN
DIE MOLLY -- SENATE PRO TEM
MEMBERS BURTON AND LOCK HERE --
AMONG SEVERAL OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS -- FOR
A COMBINED TOTAL OF TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS SPENDING FROM
1-992-220-0019 SO -- I WISH HIM
WELL AS I KNOW EVERYBODY ELSE
DOES -- WOULD APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE ON THIS
COMMITTEE AS A CONSULTANT FOR
THE LAST THREE YEARS -- AND I'M
ONLY SORRY THAT I HAVEN'T HAD
THE BENEFIT OF WORKING WITH YOU
FOR LONGER THAN FIVE MONTHS.
BUT WISH YOU WELL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
WHATEVER OTHER CAPACITY -- YOUR
ENDEAVORS TAKE YOU IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL.
AND WITH THAT DURING THE MEETING